se io vi dicessi che la sostenibilità è
un tema Sì molto oggettivo perché ciò
che è sostenibile è sostenibile ciò che
non è sostenibile non è sostenibile e
parlo del consumo di un prodotto della
vita di un prodotto dell'operato di
un'azienda o di un servizio Ma in realtà
la sostenibilità è anche un tema pieno
di compromessi o meglio per capire se un
prodotto è veramente sostenibile o no
Quindi per comprendere la vera
sostenibilità
bisogna mettere sul piatto della
bilancia dei compromessi
a chi di voi per alzata di mano perché
mi piace mi piacerebbe avere dei
feedback reali in realtà che mi servono
molto per il mio lavoro chi di voi Pensa
che l'affermazione la sostenibilità è un
tema
Sì oggettivo ma anche pieno di
compromessi chi pensa che sia ambigua
questa questa
informazione tra di voi per alzata di
mano
ma in realtà non ha tante persone o sì
non è che non vi vedo tanto bene e è
assolutamente una un'informazione
ambigua per spiegarla ci vorrebbe
Bisognerebbe filosofare un pochettino
Però in realtà io oggi non voglio
parlarvi emozionalmente del mio lavoro
perché non voglio che andiate a casa
questa sera pensando a Oggi ho sentito
parlare una brava ragazza che brava
salva pianeta dalla plastica No io
vorrei che andate a casa oggi pensando
a voler essere magari da domani dei
consumatori consapevoli
Io vi vorrò andare oggi delle nozioni
specifiche logiche e molto concrete per
avere i mezzi per
farvi delle domande e fare delle domande
alle aziende per capire
il loro operato quindi per capire se il
loro operato è realmente sostenibile o
no per capire se il prodotto che state
acquistando è veramente sostenibile o no
io tre anni fa ho aperto un Marketplace
quindi una piattaforma
che è stata la prima in Italia a
occuparsi della selezione delle aziende
anche dei prodotti in realtà sì Poi
chiaramente anche delle aziende in base
al Packaging perché
ci sono sempre stati i negozi ecobio
magari si preoccupavano della
sostenibilità degli ingredienti e magari
anche si dei diritti dei laboratori per
esempio però nessuno lo aveva mai fatto
per quanto riguarda il Packaging Anche
perché il problema della plastica è un
problema attuale
e
Ci sono
diversi aspetti in realtà del mio lavoro
io ho deciso di voler facilitare il
consumo consapevole del cittadino della
cittadina italiani
mettendo su un unico Marketplace
un'unica piattaforma i prodotti
sostenibili che all'inizio erano live
Style poi dopo mi sono specializzato in
prodotti per la cura della persona e
nella cosmetica sostenibile affinché voi
possia tutti possano
avere un punto di riferimento dove fare
la spesa sostenibile e consapevole
Però appunto come dicevo prima io vorrei
che siate in grado di farvi delle
domande avere il mezzo i mezzi per
chiedere anche alle aziende fare delle
domande alle aziende e capire veramente
Quali sono i loro intenti e il loro e il
loro operato perché anche voi dovete per
essere consapevoli dovete anche è vero
che ci sono questi Marketplace adesso
Dove si acquista si può acquistare
sostenibile Ma come voi
potete fare in realtà fare questo tipo
di acquisti dovete anche sapere fare
delle domande alle aziende per capire se
effettivamente quel negozio è il vostro
negozio di sostenibile di fiducia o no
se effettivamente quella quel negozio
quell'azienda non faccia briowashing che
per chi non lo non lo sa è appunto
mettere una maschera verde per
far sembrare l'operato storico
dell'azienda che magari è sempre stato
dannoso per l'ambiente per farlo
sembrare invece Green e quindi
continuare
a vendere quindi continuare magari anche
con l'operato dannoso
tornando al compromesso
per capire bene quali sono i compromessi
nella scelta
personale dei propri consumi quindi
proprio davanti nel momento della scelta
dell'acquisto di un prodotto
Bisogna fare degli esempi concreti
Adesso vi farò degli esempi concreti In
modo tale proprio da
mandarvi veramente a casa e capire
e potervi fare queste domande anche
quando sarete soli davanti a un prodotto
cosmetico per esempio ma anche
alimentare
che cosa bisogna Quali sono gli aspetti
di un prodotto
perché sia sostenibile intanto la
filiera la filiera Chiaramente deve
essere il più corta possibile
però se pensiamo
che
per esempio
Chi di voi sta Voglio un altro vorrei un
altro feedback reale chi lo sa tra di
voi che si possono acquistare gli
avocado siciliani ci sono delle aziende
in Sicilia una in particolare molto
grossa che è diventata così grossa che
riesce a spedire avocado online in tutta
Italia chi lo sapeva che si potevano
acquistare
in Sicilia non tante persone
purtroppo L'azienda è nuova
permette di acquistare gli avocado che
vengono dalla Sicilia che sono
chiaramente più a km 0 per gli italiani
rispetto a che comprarli al supermercato
e vengono dall'altra parte del mondo tra
l'altro E questa parte la sto
improvvisando io ho parlato questa
mattina con un ragazzo che mi ha detto e
io sono siciliano Però c'è un problema
in realtà
cioè siccità in Sicilia Abbiamo un
problema elasticità e gli avocado agli
avocado serve tantissimo acqua per
crescere
siamo andati insieme a guardare e
informarci
veramente quindi gli avocado siciliani
fossero sostenibili o meno sono questi
compromessi le coltivazioni di vocali in
Sicilia questa cosa qua l'hanno pensata
E infatti le vocali siciliani fanno
vengono coltivati a un'altitudine tale
che piove e quindi non non c'è più
questo questo problema non recano
ulteriori danno danni all'ambiente
capite se dico che è tutta una questione
di compromessi se invece non fosse stato
così chiaramente Quindi se non fosse
stato che li coltivano ad alte
a un'attitudine tale per cui piove
sarebbe veramente stato sostenibile a
questo punto
Boh
bisognava fare appunto delle analisi
il burro di karité il burro di karité è
africano quindi viene da lontano
sicuramente non a chilometro zero
è presente in Tantissimi cosmetici lo
usiamo tantissimo viene venduto
tantissimo in Italia lo usiamo anche
puro sulla pelle fa benissimo
Non è tanto chilometri lo zero non è
proprio tanto vicino a noi però
per esempio
una famiglia oppure una comunità un
gruppo di persone africane Magari sono
loro che producono il burro di karité
quindi
gli diamo lavoro Queste persone hanno
una possibilità di lavorare e quindi ma
a questo punto se noi chiediamo una
certificazione di questo tipo a
un'azienda quindi chiediamo Da dove
viene questo burro di karité che io
produce possiamo renderci renderci conto
da soli se questo prodotto è sostenibile
o meno
altro aspetto oltre alla filiera c'è
anche il discorso dei della tutela dei
laboratori o delle lavoratrici il famoso
made in China Ovviamente non è
sostenibile perché multinazionali vanno
in Cina come ben sapete a sfruttare i
lavoratori che lavorano Senza un minimo
salariale ma
neanche in condizioni
lavorative Safe
e quindi non sono tutelati però anche
qui non è che tutto ciò che arriva dalla
Cina non è sostenibile perché magari ci
sono c'è una famiglia cinese che fa
prodotti artigianali Allora sì il
prodotto è sostenibile
le spedizioni un altro tema sono le
spedizioni le spedizioni Green ci sono
tante aziende che ormai soprattutto
quelle online decidono di spedire
soprattutto gli e-commerce appunto
decidono di spedire
in maniera sostenibile senza la plastica
con scotch di carta scatole in
cartoncino bravi non siamo capaci tutti
Ormai è diventata è diventato veramente
quasi l'esempio di greenwashing più più
facile perché oppure utilizzarne i
sacchetti di carta nei negozi no
Però facendo delle domande delle aziende
parlando con le aziende per capire se
veramente l'intento delle aziende essere
sostenibili o meno si può capire per
esempio se quella azienda
Recupera del materiale per le spedizioni
perché a me è capitato che mi arrivasse
un pacco e ci fosse dentro del
polistirolo
da uno shop online che dice di spedire
invece totalmente Green ho detto Ma come
mai Scusate e allora mi hanno detto
perché questo polistirolo è stato
recuperato da un pacco grosso da parte
di un fornitore e quindi piuttosto che
inviare la tua cliente finale le chips
di mais Per imballare per riempire il
pacco ho usato quel polistirolo perché
meglio dare vita a un qualcosa di
plastica piuttosto che utilizzare
qualcosa di mais ma utilizzarlo ex novo
no Quindi c'è sempre il compromesso da
bilanciare bisogna sempre parlare con le
aziende le aziende Se veramente sono
sostenibili qualcuno che voglia di
raccontare i loro intenti hanno voglia
di raccontare il loro operato
se non hanno delle risposte al volo
prendono il cliente dicono Aspetta un
attimo mi vado a informare dal mio
produttore mi vado a informare dal mio
fornitore e chiedo faccio domande Magari
lo sprono Grazie per l'idea
effettivamente non è sostenibile
cercheremo la maniera per per riparare
troveremo un'altra soluzione
un altro aspetto
Vabbè sono gli ingredienti gli
ingredienti che che non devono
inquinare
l'ambiente e che devono essere tossici
anche per noi quindi qui possiamo
chiedere tutte le certificazioni del
mondo
Quindi noi possiamo sia chiederle
certificazioni che proprio parlare per
capire gli intenti dell'azienda perché a
volte ci sono aziende che non hanno le
certificazioni che magari non hanno
soldi per ottenerle magari sono
piccoline sono appena nate vogliono
operare in maniera sostenibile ma non
hanno i soldi per ottenere le
certificazioni parliamo con queste
aziende soprattutto le più piccoline
il Packaging tornando al Packaging di
prima visto che vi ho detto appunto che
io mi occupo specialmente di questo in
azienda Infatti io sono proprio questo
ruolo
ovvero quello della
selezione dei brand e dell'analisi nella
loro sostenibilità di tutti gli aspetti
sul Packaging
Io lavoro tanto
utilizzo Cioè ho iniziato a utilizzare
il claim Plastic free perché
effettivamente io ho voluto eliminare la
plastica dal Packaging dei cosmetici che
ho voluto introdurre sul mercato
italiano e che prima non c'erano
[Musica]
Sì però
non voglio demonizzare la plastica
perché è ovvio che la plastica vada
direttamente dispersa nell'ambiente che
ammazzi gli animali è ovvio che la
plastica
disperde microplastiche
Però anche a volte dei vantaggi Nel
senso che per esempio è molto più
leggera del vetro perché il vetro è più
pesante più voluminoso quindi servono
più serve più energia per per produrre
Packaging in vetro per spedirlo e
la plastica a volte addirittura serve
perché il Packaging sia funzionale per
il prodotto stesso quindi non è da
demonizzare vi faccio un esempio un olio
gli faccio un esempio proprio concreto
nel mondo della cosmetica un olio per le
cuticole mi viene in mente un olio che
utilizziamo centellinandolo
ha bisogno di essere ha bisogno di un
contagocce
il contagocce la struttura in plastica
la pipetta di gomma per forza perché è
solo quel la pipetta esiste solo così la
pipetta contagocce poi chiaramente c'è
la cannuccia in vetro però c'ha una
parte in plastica
non possiamo sostituirla con un'altra
soluzione perché non esiste quindi quel
pezzettino di plastica è fondamentale
perché non venga sprecato il prodotto
chiaramente quindi in questo in questo
caso è più sostenibile il Packaging con
un pezzo di plastica
sempre nel caso dell'olio c'è una
soluzione che potrebbe essere totalmente
Plastic free Ovvero lo spray in con
tutta la struttura di alluminio ma anche
quello ha bisogno di un pirulino di
plastica per non farlo schiacciare in
borsa in zaino in valigia e non farlo
perdere per cui a volte la plastica
serve appunto non può essere sostituita
voglio fare un esempio finale
che sia
che sia utile perché si comprenda bene
questo argomento fino alla fine
un prodotto solido il lo shampoo solido
lo shampoo solido che ormai è
l'esempio del prodotto Plastic free che
conoscono tutti e che stanno iniziando
ad usare tutti un po' come la bottiglia
termica dell'acqua e lo shampoo solido
uno shampoo solido venduto in non so un
negozio fast fashion che
prodotto in Bangladesh è ovviamente
anche se non ha il Packaging meno
sostenibile perché sfrutta i lavoratori
permette quel negozio fast fashion di
fare greenwashing di per esempio un
prodotto in plastica riciclata molle che
non pesa tanto e
che viene magari dentro c'è un prodotto
liquido uno shampoo liquido quindi in
plastica appunto
artigianale magari di un'azienda
italiana
che utilizza prodotti locali e
che dietro non so supporta Le api per
esempio
e in questo caso è molto più sostenibile
il prodotto in in plastica anche se non
c'è scritto Plastic free invece sullo
shampoo solido c'è scritto lo shampoo
solido venduto nella catena di fast
fashion invece lì c'è scritto Plastic
free il claim che da cui non dobbiamo
farci fregare sostanzialmente Quindi io
vi ho detto tutte queste cose perché
vorrei che appunto davanti a questi
queste parole che ormai sono ovunque
l'asset free Green sostenibilità delle
aziende che usano per fare marketing voi
abbiate
le i mezzi per capire veramente Se un
prodotto è realmente
sostenibile o meno e gli ultimi 10
secondi volevo dire un'altra cosa non
faccio in tempo io spero di venirvi in
mente
ai vostri davanti ai vostri prossimi
acquisti Grazie